bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors pour le ministre de
l'intérieur la priorité est aujourd'hui
plus que jamais le terrorisme déjà
implanté dans notre pays
expliquez nous pourquoi oui ce qu'il
faut quand même souligner c'est que le
terrorisme
pour une fois il est sympa pour une fois
mais disons qu'on sent souvent dans les
discours de nos politiques que c'est
assez fébrile pour le nommer terrorisme
islamiste là je trouve que le discours a
été a été plutôt clair et il est allé
plus loin puisqu'il a parlé d'une de ses
composantes de la menace de la menace
endogène
donc je trouve que le discours est
plutôt est plutôt très claire par
rapport à ce qu'on a entendu
précédemment
après on découvre on découvre à rien
quand il qualifie la menace de très
élevé elle est très élevé de toute façon
le fait qu on est déstabilisé les bases
arrières de l'état islamique
il a d'ailleurs il l'a dit aussi il a
expliqué que l'état islamique avait
anticipé en fait sa défaite sur ce front
là et qu'il avait organisée ou préparer
son retour dans la clandestinité avec
derrière probablement une modification
des modes opératoires c'est à dire des
des attentats probablement orchestré
toujours sur les bases sur lesquelles
ils sont à l'aise à l'étranger mais il
ya quand même beaucoup moins qu'il ya
quelques temps mais aussi les retours du
dj en europe qui qui va nous amener
aussi mais certains noms des gens
aguerris on va dire avec des modes
opératoires finalement assez qu'on
connaît qu'on connaît mais qui qui sont
qui sont durs et pour lesquels
aujourd'hui on n'est pas véritablement
suffisamment préparés et puis plus
classiquement des choses qu'on subit
déjà depuis depuis des années donc qu'il
y en a parlé de la menace endogène avec
ce qu'on a nommé du terrorisme low cost
gérald darmanin a aussi mis l'accent sur
le milieu carcéral en 2021 à près de 63
terroristes islamistes devront être
libérés contre 45 cette année
comment se fait le suivi
sept détenus j'imagine que vous verrez
qu'ils vont faire l'objet d'une
surveillance toute particulière
même après avoir purgé leur peine oui
menace toute particulière mais mais
toujours très suffisante puisque on a eu
on a eu des cas d'attentât de gens qui
avaient des bracelets etc
donc voilà enfin moi si tu sais si la
partie effectivement c'est bien qu'il le
souligne c'est la partie un peu
inquiétant qui voulaient moi j'aurais
j'aurais souhaité avoir je dirais des
plans d'action on a un discours qui est
assez clair assez réaliste assez ferme
on ne découvre pas puisque c'est quand
même la marque de ce ministre et c'est
plutôt mieux que précédemment mais mais
maintenant il faudrait il faut des plans
d'action il faut nous dire qu'est ce qui
va changer notamment peut-être
l'ajustement de notre système judiciaire
justement qui m'apparaît complètement
ubuesque par rapport à la réalité de la
menace et la menace elle est bien
qualifié mais mais nous répond ce me
paraissent encore trop trop faible wade
plan d'action vous estimez que les
mesures mises en place actuellement sont
suffisantes pour garantir la sécurité
des français
oui moi je serai oui moi je serai
notamment notamment les peines qu en
temps quand on relâche des gens dont on
pensait même si on n'a pas pu démontrer
la preuve au sens au sens de la justice
française on est sur des territoires de
guerre donc on à l'extérieur du
territoire on sait qu'il ya des gens qui
sont rentrés certains ont été se sont
exhibés avec des photos avec des têtes
décapitées à la main et ses essais des
gens dont on n'a pas pu démontrer mais
il n'y a pas de doute sur leur
détermination et sur la et ces gens là
sont pas jugés comme des criminels de
guerre ils sont ils sont jugés comme du
droit commun avec toute la souplesse
indispensable dans un pays en paix comme
la france je veux dire le jeu remet pas
en question le principe mais pour moi il
faudrait adapter même momentanément opté
pour une dizaine d'années par exemple et
durcir et durcir sur tout ce qui est en
lien avec le terrorisme le procès des
attentats de charlie hebdo et denis
payre cacher s'ouvre demain 14 personnes
seront jugées aux assises elles sont
soupçonnées d'avoir participé
ces attaques qui ont fait 17 morts en
2015 que doit-on attendre de ce procès
qu'on qualifie déjà d'historique
malheureusement enfin malheureusement
pas grand chose si vous voulez alors
c'était évident que le procès doit avoir
lieu pour les victimes c'est important
pour c'est important pour le collectif
pour la république mais on va rien
découvrir comme un conte message déjà je
veux dire les alors on nous dit ce sont
des petites mains etc
mais encore une fois on ne parle pas
d'un braquage de dab
ce sont des petites 9 ce sont les mêmes
petites mains qui servait le fascisme
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale je
veux dire c'est effectivement c'est pas
sont pas des décideurs ce sont des gens
qui ont fait de la logistique qui ont
apporté un soutien financier ou
logistique et voilà donc encore une fois
on a affaire à une idéologie on n'a pas
affaire à une opération malveillante lié
mercantile je dirais ccc idéologique
donc ce sont les mêmes petites mains qui
servait le fascisme voilà dans l'est
dans les années 40
gilles sacaze merci pour cet éclairage
je rappelle que vous êtes expert en
sûreté et ancien cadre de la direction
générale de la sécurité extérieure merci
beaucoup